Why's the flashlight all kurfubbled?
I don't want to go like this
or maybe I do wanna go like this
*intense voice* Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to the Brookhaven Experiment.
Now
I don't know if we're going to get to the very end of this
but I'm going to make a lot more progress
Hi :) I'm going to get you in a second
I'm gonna see you at the end of the game
We're gonna have a nice tea party
and then you can go FUCK YOURSELF!
Alright, so let's get back into the campaign
Now, obviously we left off at a good point
[Weird Voice] in the sewers
And that means that we're gonna have FUN
[Normal] What's the Sangamon Forest?
But hopefully this is gonna get harder and harder
[that's what she said]
as this goes on and hopefully
I recojiggered my setup so that hopefully
it's a little bit better than it was before
You can see that
That one's just a little bit higher
they should be tracking just a little-
OHHH NOW YOU'RE GONNA'N STOP ME AND SO FUCKY ON ME (Marki do you even English)
okay, ooo
Oh... Oh! That's a good sign!
Oh I'm happy about that!
(Overly Honest Markimoo) All the feelings of emotions are evacuating out of my bowels!
Oh boy.
OHH boy.
OH BOY!
(Almost Mickeyplier) HO BOY!!
Okay anyway
I need to get more weapons 'cause good god, I'm not...
I'm sucking it up a lot, alright
New area, I'm gonna start with the laser sight because
I'll be goddamned if I'm gonna be fucked over by any of THIS bullshit
WAIT, buff upgrade- goddamnit I forgot about that
Alright,
the stun grenade gives off a blindin--*Pop*
Kelley: Hello, this is Kelley.      Mark: Hi
Kelley: There should be fire down there so you don't get lost in the dark when flashlight batteries run out.
Mark: Uh (fuck)
Kelley: There are many who have been going out on forties (?) every day
Mark: Uh
Kelley: not to supply as a rescue but to keep the flames going just in case someone needs them like we do now
Mark: What?   Kelley: Over
Mark: Wait...
There's people that come down here on a regular basis, just to keep
to keep the fires going??
FOR ONCE IN A HORROR GAME YOU ACTUALLY EXPLAIN
WHY THERE'S FIRE?!?!?! *gunshots* (Darkiplier resurfaces)
I'm so happy
whoa aahhh eeeeehhh
it's a parade of babies!!! (wtf mark)
a parade of fucking babies (pls never have children) AHH!!!
What you think you're doing? FREEZE! woah, hey, what the fuck, get outta here!
well they're sneaking up on me oh I see
something way back there
ah muzzle brake I don't know what that
does
ooo, they're all over me! ok, can't spin in a
circle because I've done that before
whoa well that doesn't sound good
ah damn it hang on...BOINK
ok hooo man I can't believe they
finally justified a goddamn reason
there's a glow stick
there's a monster and for- woah AAAHHHH
OOOH OH NO- oh hello, man, hello
yeah and you'd think they would have done a
better job of lighting up the goddamn
fires i still can't see shit in here
oh man i guess i can't complain I didn't
think anyone would dedicate any sort
of human resources to be able to just
light some goddamn fires in a
zombie-infested hellhole (tru that)
ok that's recoiling a lot more than I
remember
ok one coming down there so far so goo goo
and I like it goo goo what you doing you
better not come any closer
ooh Imma really give it to yah AAAGH!! aw
that was a warning shot
it's a good thing i'm incredibly stupid (yup sure is Mark)
nope still missed
there we go well that's going well fuck
off (nope)
now i just realized I'm standing in a
pile of filth (shit*)
I don't have a potty mouth (sure you don't) oh there we
go well let's skip that
thank you I know what I'm all about I
know what I'm about and I'm about a lot
of skill-BOINK! I'm not about taking any
dablage but at least I got a muzzle brake
maybe there's something else down there
but I'm not oh hey. Bayum oh that's right i
didn't get the goddamn what i needed oh,
greatly reduce recoil
I'll take that I'll definitely take that
and the extended clip that's what I was
Hey! Well that's kinda cool, it makes my gun
look all nice and neat-o!
bah-bah-bah-bah-bah boink
ok maybe that'll be useful for looking
down the hallway so I can get some
illumination on whatever the, the gift
boxes that they got Storm drains are
going to be safe to travel to find
yourself in a parlor thats where they nest and feed the ones
with eight legs they drive victim
[INCOMPREHENSIBLE]  and wrap them in a webbing to be consumed at leisure
oh oh oh oh gaaagh!! what are you!?!?!
oh that's new oh you're not coming near
me
oh you're still coming near me okay (seriously Mark) aah!! eeh!! eh aaaaah!!! I dont like that!!!
oh I don't like that Oh ooh ooh ooh I don't
know
(Marks battlecry) flashlights useless!!
Oh no ah
hey hows it going *gun shots* damn it *more gunshots*
okay well this is incredibly terrible
and I hate everything (when do you not)
my life is in shambles... oh? *sniffles* eh
where are you there are you yeah that aint good
that's not a good sound
AH!! WHAT THE FUCK!?!?! GET OFF OF ME!!!
who did that who di... who the fuck did that someone over there eeeh! get off
of my face
ooooh oh that aint good!! (you think)
AAAGH THAT AINT GOOD!!
aagh!! I can't see!! aagh shit!!
its ow fucking whose doing tha.. AAAGH!!! WHAT THE FUCK!!!
when did you get so close to me god damn it don't
stand so close to me (bruh)
Fuck man... AAAAGH!!! fucking hell!!!
oh god oh god oh good god be with you in
a goddamn second
oh geez this got all sorts of worse
I thought I heard something oh boy
ah ok aach!! ahaach!!
ah!! AAH!!
ah shit ah god damn it he gooped up my gum
aagh my guns all goopy!!! AAAGH!! (calm down Mark)
ok this is way harder oh this is
definitely harder (thats what she said)
oooh I'm not about this I see you over
there
there you are hoo
oh ok Wow
holy shit balls and ass cock (aah classic mark)
this is getting intense there we go well
let's do it oh man
oh mama gamba oh mama popamba whoa Nelly
ok so i can do I can do without that I
can do without that because apparently i
think they changed it so i don't i'm not
completely blinded when I'm low on
damage which is a nice change if they
did that
ok Bob standard armor-piercing do extra
damage go through multiple targets that
sounds awesome
do I have a limited amount of that I
just have unlimited because that's
amazing i want that okay
what happened to my illumination flares
I had three of those ah whatever
can't complain now hold the.. did the bullet go
flying woah nice
ok stun grenade I don't I don't nee... boo!! (who you trying to scare Mark)
ok where's there's got to be like a got
to be like an ammo or ok looking for the
ammo looking for the helpful helpy
helpertons that are going to
give me a brand new gun
where are you where the fuck are you
that's way better about the recoil by
the way it's way better about the recoil
way way way better
who oh I see you up there (its Jesus Mark go to him) *gunshots* AAAAAAGH!!! *splat noise* ew grody
all right where you at way down there
all right i don't see I don't see
another crate i'm really trying to look
for it now i'm really trying to look for
em
ok whoa that's a big guy down there (oh no kill him before he kills you)
I love that lower recoil love just
checking to see if I got any surprises
around here *Marks rapid gunshots*
EEEAAT MY DIIICK!!!
anybody whoa woah what is that
oh shit fuck okay hang on
he jumped over my bul-AAAGH!!
whoa fuck off with you ah shit
okay we got incoming but we got god I
nailed him. FIRE!! FIRE DOWN THE HALLWAYS!!!
okay we this who do you think you
is
huh do you think he was trying to ho-AAAGH
that aint good woah
can i dodge it and I dodge that.. WOAH!!!
hey buddy okay so far so good doing
good on battery
yes killing it killing it killing it
killing them killing them SLIDE SLIDE SLIDE SLIDE
SLIDE SLIDE!!!!!! (what are you doing)
ok
oh my god taking a drink of water
killing zombos requires a lot of energy
and these levels just so happened to be
much more involved
ok so I'm going to just going to heal up
my health because this is getting pretty
dicey and I don't wanna I don't wanna have to
worry about getting hit to death
this late into the level because I
imagine that if you die you got to start
the level all over again with this is
going to be a huge problem later
and those armor-piercing rounds that's
fucking amazing is focking awesome mwate
the closest enemy is not always the
most dangerous
I know that whoa who's down there whoa
what is that whoa what is that
what are you? EEEH ITS A BUTTHOLE!!!
AAAGH A BUTTHOLE IS COMING AT ME!!!
ho geez oh its the thing from Penumbra AAAAAGH!!! (ooh a classic)
oh geez well I'm geez I'm trying my best
yeah you better run away fuck you dude
fuck you you're floating butthole oh
there's another one aaaaaagh!!! this one might beat me
well geez oh geez oh geez oh geez oh
geez oh that's right back off
who marky no likey you know like II told you no
likey at all
ok any crates and crates looking four
crates looking for friendly while
parking lot
ok who's doing that shit
muzu well wait while we're yeah yeah
oh I hate that I hate that nope no no
nope you're dead down there are you all
AAAGHHHH
I just wanted to learn your lesson real
bad
you come here look at this is that
smelled like gunpowder to you are you at
Oh... Aghhhh I see you up there
there you are whoa big guy
Ahhh I'm spunned, oh shit what's happening
Whooa
oh geez
Whoa oh God AAAGGH I didn't see you, OOH, that's terrifying
well geez that's bad AHH fuck off with you
holy shit AAGHG, OH NO, NO (x5)
NOO, whoa whoa
fuck off well
fuck you whoa fuck you man fuck you fu- AAAHH
I'm trapped in money (What?) ah shit, fuck off with you fuck you and you and you
holy shit holy shit balls cock and ass
black jack black
huh (out of shape) who's doing it I'm out of battery
no it looked upset hi don't know why
huh, huh
(different voice) as much as it was frustrating to speak
it tears me up when I don't see your
position update even going to clear path
of hospitals before you proceed
I hope you can move soon we're wasting
like cali out huh
(Markifart) oh good I'm so sorry you're worried (weird voice)
about me
I'm so sorry that I have to spend my
whole goddamn life in this fucking
hellhole that you put me in
oh man
whew all right that was nuts, that was nuuuuuuts, that was nuts, that was, that was no joke, that was nuts
analyst cap i scammed a lot of ammo but
I didn't get a new gun I'd really like a
new gun ok reservoir it is (nonsense)
oh boi everything still good on the
recording everything still good
probably i'm going to assume that that's a yeess-
probably definitely
Uh oh where am I? Hooo ok, okay hang on let me get a good look at what I- ooh
good so there's going to be at least one
worm that's going to try to crawl its
way up mah butt hole
well hopefully I won't have to worry
about that too much
kind of looks like a scene from "Left 4
Dead" Haboink! all right but other than that
*sigh* I need th- I need the, fire ray
like I would love to have the uh
I would love t-
uughah, all right
I would love to have the uh
whew all their things, that's beautiful
what the fuck was that
Kelley: Rama, this is Kelley. Looks like you're out of the storm drain.
Mark: yeah
Kelley: That's the Woodford County Reservoir in front of you.
Mark: ah ha!
Kelley: Take in your surroundings, and once safe to move
find your way to the bridge and start
heading north
Mark: Are you thinking I sh-
Kelley: I'm setting up the peoria camera
Mark: Yo- you you think I move right away you
think you think that'd be a good old
whoo whoo
hey, no
all right whoa
*Gunshots*
we got close quarters here I'll tell you
what
shit!
AAHHH! Fuck you what the fuck he was just
standing there always waiting for me to
kill him
Ho, he wanted the sweet embrace of
death, I was happy to provide. Whew!
oh man oh man this is getting, this is getting legit like scary
Whoa Fuck you wwhooaaahey fuck off with you
Whew! This is getting legit wow it's so legit scuearry. What is it, there's something down there
Gah, ok whew! (Dog barking noises) I got saved my bad around being bad about that
I only got a 87 left I mean I didn't
take any damage but at least you know I got through it ok
oh man this game is starting to get my
heart going
Hoo, get out of here we got things to do has something happened out here
I was worried that something fell down but I heard a noise in real life but apparently it was not.
Hokay, everything's fine everything's fine
Mag ammo. I wish I had a mag did I-
wait did i get a gun
I didn't actually see what I got when I
shot that case, did I get a gun
Oh! Oh a Megiddo
Oh a Meggiddo! I got a Megiddo
Oh! I don't have enough ammo for the
megiddo but I got it
I'll get you later next time I'm gonna
stick with this because I got a lot of bullets for it
So now I don't need to be wasteful right. I can be wasteful I- I don't need to be conservative
not that I've been conservative at all
i've been very much spastic about my
bullet usage but you know it's fine
"Be on the lookout for weapon and upgrade crates - shoot them to acquire new gear."
yeah I know that now. Whoa whoa ho hey! Hi!
whoa what the fu- AHHH fuck off with you
jesus oh God
ok whoa where is he
Bam bam bam bam bam wham bam. Thank you ma'am. Ah shit whoa hey!
Fuck off! Damn it. Caught that guy just a little bit too late.
Eeh, whoa hey, hey buddy, do you have two heads? Nope, you have no heads =].
Ah eugh fuck what's that, oh shit. you know these armor piercing rounds don't really pierce as much as advertised
Wheoh
AH! Fuck off god! oh damn it that's really
close
Come on, oh who's d- AAAH FACK OFF! Fuck, with the fucking shoot, SHOOT!
Ah, damn it, geeeeeeeeeeezums.
Whoa that did a lot. Whoa heeey
*Sings  "Heigh Ho"* Ho, who's doing that. HEY! Fuck yoou. Whooew! Oh man, this is not going too well.
Ah fucking...Uueh fuck.
I think I gotta shake it off it's not what I was doing I wasn't doing the thing with the shaking.
Whhhheeeeww! Ah, no nono no. No no, I will dodge you all day. All day mother humper!
HA! Oh, all day mother humper. All day mother humper!
alllLLLL day! Ah, I don't care. I'll go full, baujsdf (something) trigger all over you! What's the name.
Time crisis! I'll go full time crisis on you bbuuuieeeetch!
It's where you go, BBBBWWWAAAHHHHH! That did not work,  but you can assume that that went well. And then assume also that I was cool. SSSHHIIIEEET
Gad, blouw!
Ok, not with the mag because i don't want to be left out in the lurch and nothing
because i don't know if it's gonna be
snore-or smart enough to switch a weapon on me
*Sigh* that's not the gun I want--that's
that's not the gun I want.
Oh, that'd be nice that'd be nice I just
don't have enough bullets
unless naaah I don't have enough bullets
I got too many small things to waste
ammo on that. Haboink, haboink, haboink, haboink, haboink, habloink, habloink, habloooiiink, okay
whoo Nelly wow it's getting fuck i got i
got so turned around last time a fire
and illumination flare into the sky for
better visibility
Wow that'd be nice to know they didn't
know that i didn't use that I've never
used one before in my life
Saw you over ther.
that guy was hard hit
save the ammo save the ammo, ooooo, I keep thinking something's gonna- whhheooow
sa- wwheeoow
Ah, who's do- AH, fucking get off of me
there we go you do shake it, you do shake it. Who's in there, oh shit!
whoa, ok we got something
Heeeeyyy ho, hey ho- ahhhhhhhhhhh
oh shit that's a lot of spiders coming
from in there uuuahhgh ok so far so goo
Who's up there?
Ahh! Who's doing that? Who shit. Oh shit.
god dammit i keep thinking from above not above from the side from side who scitter scatter. Scitter scatter
that's right get down whoa. Not above
whoa. HHAAAAAAA. HAAAAAOU. ok
yeah I'm like a cowboy. Cowboy rampage!
except i'm about to die. AHH ok whoa fuck
I didn't know I have to be dodging nothing here
Ahh! Oh fuck AH my head, mah face, ah, my back and crack, pussy! Whatever the thing is
Aaahhhhh shit.
Ugh, I'm getting real tangled now
WWWWWOOOOOOOOOO!!!
WWWOOOOOOO! Oh let me make sure that I'm not
oh my god damn *babay noises*
oh fuck, let me get a drink. Alright!
sorry about the little breather I needed
god damn it was getting intense
okay but I don't have that luxury i'm
going to use the illumination flare this time
I'm gonna use it right off the bat
so that i have it, come on give me-
where is it that's not it
that's where where's my no don't wait
how do I-
wait what wait no don't
Don't close man don't quit don't quit (RAGEIPLIER) don't fucKING QUIT! WHAT THE FUCK! WHAT THE FUCK!
QUIT?!?!
WELL WHY DID IT QUIT, THERE WAS NO POWER BUTTON TO QUIT!!
WHAT THE FUCK, THERE'S NO BUTTON ON HERE THAT SAYS "QUIT!"  (We get it Mark) I TRIED T- WHAT THE FUCK!
Are you fucking kidding me?! What the fuck was that? I was looking for the goddamn flare!
Are you fucking serious?! I've got to go through all of that again! Motherfucker!
Are you fucking serious?! What the fuck happened?! (Mark, calm ur tits)
I didn't fucking have a choice! YOU DIDN'T GIVE ME A GODDAMN CHOICE!!!!!
What the fuck does that mean?! "Press again to not quit."
WHAT KIND OF FUCKING BULLSHIT OPTION IS IT TO "Press to not quit" IT SHOULD BE "Press to confirm the quit"
NOT PRESS "Oh shit here's a countdown before we
exit your game and you lose your fucking progress!" *Sighs*
There's no reason to have "Oh, did you mean that, we're going to make sure" *Background noise*
"We're gonna make sure, but do it anyway!" (Are you done ranting Mark?)
Whoa hey whoa hey whoa. Haha ha ha ha ha. Go ahead and (something). Uh oh, DODGE. AH MAH FACE!
Whu, AH fuck you, you little shits. Little shits.
*Moans* *Mockery laugh*
Oh, that sounds gurgley again. Is it a gurgley guy?! Is it gurgle a gan? Might be. Oh shit, wheoh fuck. Euh shit, shit!
Shit, shoot, fucking Chriminey , I had to get their blood exploding all over mah butt!
Alright, so far so guuuuuooolllll
So far so guuuooollluol. What a beautiful moonlit night!
what a wonderful time to be murdering creatures from the beyond, AAHH oh goddamn it
I see you down there
AH, WHAT THE FUCK?! AAAGGHHH WHAT THE FUCKING FUCK?!
AHHH ugggh.
Kelley: You are going going to survive.
Mark: What?
Kelley: As few of us remain, it falls to us to find a reason to persist.
But we not dare speak the reason we got here. (?)
Mark: Huuughh? (me too)
Kelley: If your way is clear, follow the bridge and find me.
Mark: I didn't know- I didn't know there was gonna be twos. I didn't know it's going to be dubleh (heh)
How would I have known it was going to be Michael Dubleh. FUCK! Alright, we'll carry on.
I will carry on nnow that I don't have to replay a son of a bitch, we'll carry on.
OOHH, I scravenged a boouonch. *sigh* Fuck man. Alright.
Whoo! I'm going to keep going I just need another drink. It's getting quite warm in here.
I can't run the air when I'm in here.
Ahh. And all the lights don't help. (I can relate.)
Ueuh, alright. Let's do this. LIUHGA. Wait, bridge, I'm literally going right up there!
Why couldn't I have taken a lengthier jaunt on mmy way to death?
huh huh okay should I try the megiddo
I'll give it a go
the megiddo ago haha i am silly bitch
Oh God well I'll give the critical hit
one. Farmer Pearson
WHOO! That's got a thump to that one! That's not gonna get annoying anytime soon.
Alright, who wants one? I can't miss.
Kelley: This bridge will take you to Sangamon Forest... or what's left of it.
Can you smell the char?
Mark: *sniffs* Naho
Kelley: Parts of the forest still smolder. The first breach was torn open  and peoria caverns inside the forest .
We were miles away from Brookhaven. We didn't know what was happening, until the news reported the forest fires.
Even then, we didn't know *gunshot*
Mark: The forest fires, huh, well Smoky did warn you.
Blam! Blam! Oh, four (4) whoa, ah shit!
Get off of me. Hey, hey, no, no, ah shit.
Ah shit, nu, nu, no no no no no. Whoa. That one's got some oomph to it!
I don't know if it's gonna be good for my main. OOOHHH (orgasm) one shot! Holy shit! Oh my word!
The only thing that's not good for those little shits. Wheoh, I'll be with you in a second.
I gotta make sure there's no little shits coming my way.
I need um-- oh there's a chest shot for you.
headshots are for losers like you and
you and you and you and
Oh shit, ah shit, get back. Get back honky- oh I hit him.
i forgot that i can melee with my
swing a hammer
Oh, hello. AHH. I ran right into that.
that was my bad. Whoah, hey. Habum, habum, habum, habumbabumbabumba-
OH-HOHOHOHOHO. Two (2) in a line!
I am loving this gun
This is, this is quite an oomphy pistol. And I like my pistols oomphy.
I like everything oomphy. I need more oomph my life and I just gotta sweep the
backhand i just got bitch-slapped the
little babies (bich whet)
goddamnit I want one of those. I'm going with Megiddo again.
magnum Megiddo
Bwam, bwam.
Alright.
I'm afraid to open the menu because I'm afraid it's gonna quit on me. Is that...
Nah, I thought the- oooh?
Hey hey, OOH. Lupara! Lucario!
Holy shit that's going to be awesome
soon as I can get that and get some ammo for it.
Boink. *Laughs nervously* You died :D
Bam. I don't even know if you were alive to begin with, but you're dead now!
Hello! (Hi!) Oh thanks for lying- oh thanks for lying- let me see.
BISH! Oh fuck you!
Ah, shit. Get off of me. Get off of me. Bam. Uh, shit. Get off of me.
Ah, fuck. Fucking, fucking. Whoa whoa. Who's there? Knock knock? (Who's there?)
you didn't say who's there (Yes I did!). knock-knock (Who's there?!).
Fuck you. Fuck you. Fuck you. Fuck you. (Oh, you're nice)
Hey. wwwhOOOAH. Mah face! Get it off. Get it off (That's what you get for being rude ):<)
There we go. Kaboink
Oh man, I love the showers of blood (That's disturbing). WHOA, two in a row! Did I ge- ahhh I hit ya.
You just didn't die, like I told you to. Whoao.
Ah, fucking chriminey with that.
Blam. Blam.
Hoooo. HOOOOOOO.
*Giggles* (Shit, Mark, that's creepy)
oh man this is great for people like me
that don't have a lot of skill that
Oh shit, well, come here, come here! I got a hug for ya! BIIITCH! Oh, fuck off!
That guy didn't want to die. I mean, I don't think any of these guys want to die, but...
I don't really have a choice in the
matter
Hello. (Hi)
Oh shit. Forgot how to reload for a
second. Boink, boink. Thank you (you're welcome)
i'm going to just switch this over to
the knife it doesn't work too well but
I imagine it will work well in conjunction with this. Because I seem to have plenty of light.
I don't need really a lot of light
so might as well go in the kill creek
What does that say? Ti-tan-i-um. If only I had a flashlight!
Oooo, ooooo. I got a shotgun. I forgot about that. But I don't want to risk it.
I mean it can't possibly take that much
ammo to kill everybody here but i still
don't want to risk it and I'm not a risky
guy. Ok what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
I don't even need the laser sight
I'll take the muzzle brake actually I'll
take that
I need the extended clip is what I need. Ah reversing. Mmmmmm, fuck you, ballz.
I call grenades the "Fuck You Ballz"
"When aiming, focus on the front of the gun sight instead of the target." How about no? I'm gonna look at the target dead in the eye.
When I... kill him... and tell his family  oh the uh-oh-uh dirty deeds that I have done.
Where are ya, I can't see ya. Where ya at? Huh? You over the- oh, oh.
Ahh. AHHH shit.
Oh. I'm good.
Hang on, I'll be right with ya. She gon- clear the forest out of these buggers here.
Whoa, fuck you.
Whoa! Fuck off.
FUK FUK U FUK, god fucking, why does that not work? Ohhhhh, shit. Whoa shit. UH OH!
Fuck off with you!
Oh shit, this is a bad sign. WhaaAAAaa
AHHHH, oh fuck, WHOOOOA shit. Fuck you, oh fuck, ah fuck. (We get it)
Ah shit, well this is going poorly for me. (We can tell)
AHHH! Fuck.
Something- whoa! Hey. Don't. Don't.  Don't. Don't. Don't. Don't (Don't what?).
Alright, we're fine, everything's fine.
Don't. Don't. Don't (DON'T WHAT PLZ EXPLAIN).
Is that dawn approaching?  Am I going out of my mind or is it starting to turn day?
What was that you were saying about
losing moonlight this- I think it's a good thing we're losing moonlight.
Unless they get really active during the day or some bullshit like that.
(different voice) You are close now. The caves shouldn't be hard for you to find.
(Mark) Really?
(different voice) Please hurry.
(Mark) *moans* I shall hurry! Thank you! Any minute now!
HHEEEEEEEIIII- ok.
What did I scavenge? And where am I going next?
Ooooooo, that is a good scavenge. That's a quality scav. Jjggunggj
Oh the Sangamon Forest. It's not quite day yet but maybe that illumination was just the fire.
So anyway, that's all I'm going to do for this episode. Sorry, to cut it quote on quote short,
I still know that this is still a long video, but
I was gonna get to the end of it but there is a lot of levels ahead of me, and I got
cock-blocked by the fe- the thel- the game restarting and me getting angry (Remember fifteen (15) minutes ago)
but either way, that is the "Brookhaven Experiment". There's probably one (1) more episode to go
before we get to the end of  this, but THANK YOU everybody so much for watching
and as always, I will see you in the next video bye-bye!!!! (Bye Mark!!!)
AHHH FUCK YOU! WHAT THE FUCK!
Hokay, FUCK OFF